alors versera caisson palais quillan
hommage national à charles aznavour et
je crois alors vous avez une petite
pancarte oui ou non alors peut-être
qu'on a un qui éloigne en ont mais voilà
en tout cas je vous rappelle les faits
c'est vrai qu'au départ la famille ne
voulait pas d'hommage national
voilà la famille voulait faire vraiment
quelque chose entre eux comme ils vont
le faire demain à montfort l'amaury et
ils vous ont voulu quelque chose de très
digne et c'est l'élysée donc et
notamment le chef de l'état qui ont
vraiment insisté ils ont dit voilà avec
le rayonnement qui a donné charles
aznavour dans le monde à la france et le
rayonnement aussi qu'il a donnée pour la
langue française
il fallait absolument je vous le dis que
charles aznavour soir il ya un hommage
national pour charles à savoir l'or ce
matin j'ai la chance d'y être c'est vrai
qu'il ya eu le président aussi arméniens
qui a fait un discours et on avait tous
des voix là on avait des petits et les
petits casques parce qu'il y avait un
interprète en fait parce que forcément
nahon comprenait pas voilà ce qu'ils y
la fin très très bel hommage à charles
aznavour et c'est vrai que ce matin
voilà moi je vous le dis tout le monde
était très ému et il y avait de la
tristesse mais il y avait surtout une
envie douala d'être d'être auprès de
charles aznavour pour voilà pour pour le
voilà pour pour être avec lui pour être
avec sa famille dans ses derniers
moments et et vraiment je trouvais que
c'était c'est un très très bel hommage
et je trouve voilà sans vouloir faire de
politique que le chef de l'état fait un
très beau discours est celui qui
l'auteur du discours et et lui qu'il
interprétait je trouve que le discours
était très beau je sais pas si vous
l'avez écouté chez vous vous êtes tous
d'accord pour dire oui eric naulleau et
le fallait oui mais j'ai trouvé dommage
magnifique mais moi c'est encore la
tristesse qui domine moi je réglerai
vous avez pleuré
moi j'étais à côté de dany brillant
aussi alors et un moment c'est vrai que
je l'entends et il éclate en sanglots
parce qu'il me dit voilà c'était c'était
mon idole et voilà il me dit c'est chez
gt avec plein de gens aussi qui me
disaient voilà on est on est tous triste
parce que on le croyait vraiment
immortel charles nabet logement qui a eu
cet hommage national parce que c'était
beaucoup plus qu'un immense chanteur
c'était un poète national et poète
national hommage national c'est bien que
la famille ait accepté en dernière
minute je trouve ça beau et la famille
était vraiment d'une tristesse
incroyable notamment ses fils sa fille
katia que j'embrasse fort voilà que je
connais très bien
jean rachid bien sûr son son gendre
c'est vrai qu'ils étaient tous très très
triste mais il était limite je voulais
je vous dis ce qui m'a ce qui m'a frappé
ce qui m'a touché aussi ce qui c'était
limite gêné qu'on fasse tout ça passe
ils voulaient voilà il voulait aussi
porter le deuil de leurs pères ou voilà
de leur beau père voilà tranquillement
entre eux et c'est vrai que jamais
l'impression qu'ils essaient trop voilà
on en est
et voilà ils sont contents de se
retrouver demain mais il était quand
même très fier de cet hommage qui lui a
été rendu aux karim zéribi non c'était
c'est un artiste hors norme et charles
aznavour mais moi ce qui m'a frappé qui
ce que je garderai aussi à l'esprit
c'est l'immense personnalités mettent
une personnalité hors norme
aussi parce que c'est un français qui
était fier d'être français il le
rappeler il le disait il parlait très
bien de la france
mais n'oubliez pas d'où il venait et est
aussi très attaché à l'arménie ce matin
dans l'hommage ça a été dit sur cette
capacité à dire je suis fier d'être
français mais je suis fier aussi de mes
origines
c'est quelque chose j'ai envie de dire
dont on a besoin dans la société
française aujourd'hui avec tous ces
débats sur l'identité
ces débats sur la simulation bien qu'il
n'ya pas d'assimilation et chez charles
aznavour français oui
amoureux de notre langue des valeurs de
la république mais aussi fier de ses
origines chère de son histoire et je
pense que c'est nécessaire pour
l'ensemble des français d'être un peu
dans cette posture là sur le plan
identitaire de ne jamais oublier d'où on
vient mais de savoir aussi ce que la
france nous a donné ce que la france
nous donne et la grandeur de notre pays
alors il ya plein de gens bien sûr
qu'ils sont venus ce matin jeudi à
l'aube des gens du showbiz bien sûr il y
avait laurent gerra il y avait dit
mitchell y avait il y avait bien sûr y
avait dany boon et il y avait tout le
monde politique puisqu'il y avait
françois hollande et et nicolas sarkozy
qui était là et c'est vrai que moi je
les regarde et je voulais absolument
voir si françois hollande et nicolas
sarkozy a laissé parler puisque françois
hollande a été placée à côté de carla à
côté de carla bruni et c'est vrai qu'ils
se sont ils se sont parlés j'avais
l'impression que françois hollande
voulait absolument
voilà il voulait absolument aller parler
à nicolas sarkozy il n'arrêtait pas
malade un peu l'interpeller sur des
choses et c'est vrai voilà nicolas
sarkozy était plus on écoute en voilà et
françois hollande était voilà était plus
on allait plus le chercher vous avez
regardé les au mal oui c'était très sale
à neige très protocolaire très émouvant
très sobre c'était absolument parfait
évidemment ils le méritaient vu le
rayonnement de toute son oeuvre
mais en revanche je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce plan dira karim il ya
une phrase moi que je retiens chez
charles aznavour c'est qu'il disait
qu'il était 100% arménien et l 100 %
français exactement il dit pas je suis
50 50
en fait il a autant aimer la france
qu'il a aimée l'arménie et je pense
qu'on n'a vraiment
tiré de cette de cette manière de
concevoir la binationalité aujourd'hui
dans notre pays
moi y'a un truc je me suis demandé vous
avez peut-être pouvoir répondre à ma
question c'est emmanuel macron mine de
rien il n'avait jamais fait ça non un
hommage national de comment ça se passe
et ce qu'il répète qu'avant parce qu'on
voit qu'il ya vraiment un protocole
vraiment qu'ils respectaient puisqu'il
doit se mettre à telle place à tel
moment
il doit se déplacer à tel moment il doit
passer de tel ou tel côté du cercueil
comment ça se passait ce que quelqu un c
est ce qu il ya des répétitions avant ou
est ce qu'il ya quelqu'un qui le guide
parce qu'il avait quelqu'un a dit qu'il
est quand il est arrivé dans la cour des
invalides
emmanuel macron avait une personne à
côté nuit qui lui glisser des petites
choses je voyais qu'il parlait avec lui
lui disais ce que tu crois que vous
nommez l'âge mais là donc s comment ça
se passait ce que quelqu'un réponde
andré bercoff ça se passe enfin il ya
tout un protocole évidemment il ya la
distribution dans l'espace comment il
doit aller tu sais il faut aussi dire
que demain il faut rendre hommage
et ce n'est pas du tout diminuer les
mérites dominé le maquereau de dire de
parler de la personne qui a écrit ce
texte mais sont acquis et sylvain fort
qui est un spécialiste de saint-exupéry
qui est un merveilleux écrivain et ce
texte qui est formidable qui est très
très très beau vraiment il faut le
célébrer jour est juste ajouter quelque
chose à ce qui s'est dit sur
l'assimilation charles aznavour était un
très grand
assimiler ce qu'ils disaient il lisait
la phrase de romain gary
il disait je n'ai pas une goutte de sang
français mais la france coule dans mes
veines faut bien voir c'est ce qu'on a
retenu du discours du président c'est
vraiment il a vraiment mis le doigt
vraiment là-dessus et il a vraiment puis
là dessus en vain de gens bien sûr lui
ont rendu hommage ce matin notamment
laurent gerra regarder et mais moi ce
vraiment si gm des choses à retenir
celle et voilà les foules et les moments
de rire avec lui je garderai ça
deviendrait son son sourire à table
quand on se retrouvait il régnait aussi
lorsque vous limitiez il me charrière
c'est à dire qu'il aimait canton quand
tu le faisais à ses côtés
glee c'est toujours un petit mot pour
nous faire attendre déstabiliser bonne
guerre évidemment alors on a voulu se
faire un petit plaisir ce soir on a
sélectionné les duos les plus
emblématiques de charles aznavour et je
voudrais dire aussi bravo à stéphane
hasbanian et mini version qui ont
organisé la cérémonie et qui était très
réussie minable ce qu'ils ont organisée
vraiment en très peu de temps et c'est
vrai qu'à organiser une cérémonie comme
ça moi je suis organisé les bar mitsva
voilà je s'organiser des mariages les
divorces mais je ne sais pas organiser
ça c'est vrai que c'est assez compliqué
regarder les meilleurs duos de charles
aznavour
[Musique]
mes amis mes amours mes emmerdes
les amis s'est fait autant pas de
javaux
vous êtes très bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vexé c'est plus facile regarder mourir
ce voyage
dans les
et
tu vois
[Musique]
sur la
c
le
murray
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]